[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au vélodrome
nationale pour le tout premier salon du
livre de saint quentin en yvelines voici
le sommaire les visionnaires premier
salon du livre organisé par saint
quentin en yvelines plus de 80 auteurs
présents au programme dédicaces
animations et conférences le prix du
livre de saint quentin en yvelines a été
décerné à michael christie pour son
roman lorsque le dernier arbre il a été
remis par le président du jury guillaume
martin et enfin lors de ce salon du
livre des cafés d'auteur sont proposés
entre lecteurs et écrivains ils
permettent un échange autour des
ouvrages des auteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me trouve au vélodrome nationale pour
le tout premier salon du livre organisé
par saint quentin en yvelines nommer les
visionnaires cet événement rassemble
près de 80 auteurs le thème le monde de
demain éric allain ginès bonsoir vous
êtes donc le vice président à la culture
de saint quentin en yvelines alors
pourquoi d'agglomération de saint
quentin ville organise en 2022 son tout
premier salon du livre le livre a été en
première ligne je dirai au moment de la
pandémie ce vélodrome a été un lieu
majeur dans cette aventure collective
que nous avons vécue comme étant le
premier centre de vaccination et je
trouve que symboliquement il était
important de réunir le livre dans ce
vieux pour parler de l'avenir enfin et
appréhender le monde de demain on vous
l'avait dit ce sont près de 80 auteurs
donc sur qui sont ici un sur deux jours
ce sont des auteurs de tous genres
confondus comment vous avez fait pour
les sélectionner et bien oui en effet ce
sont des auteurs de tous genres
confondus d'avec avec
ouvrage qui s'adresse aux au plus petit
mais aussi aux adolescents aux adultes
toutes les a tous les publics et l'idée
le thème directeur donc de cette
première édition c'est la ville de
demain saint quentin en yvelines est une
terre d'innovation et si on veut innover
il faut appréhender les choses il faut
les réveiller les imaginer il faut
savoir se projeter dans l'avenir et l'
expertise de tous ces auteurs nous est
précieuse sept employés au dire des
trois auteurs je peux vous citer déjà au
moins ceux qui ont ce qu'ils ont
concouru pour le premier prix du livre
de saint quentin du salon de saint
quentin en yvelines y'avait delphine de
vigan michael christie et gaspard koenig
étoffer la liste voici aussi d'autres
auteurs également présents sur ce salon
du livre
[Musique]
numérique la qualité urbaine en question
pose la question de l'incidence du
numérique dans les pratiques que les
citadins ont de la ville et il s'agit de
comprendre quelles sont les conséquences
de nos usages du numérique sur notre
relation à la ville mais notre rapport
aux autres aussi dans l'est dans
l'espace public urbain
globalement en une une centaine de pages
200 pages j'essaie de vous expliquer ce
qui a deux dans ce petit appareil et
surtout ceux qui a derrière pour essayer
de démystifier l'objet et puis vous
montrer que finalement même si la
vitrine est belle l'arrière boutique et
peut-être des fois un peu sombre
c'est un livre qui raconte l'histoire de
deux jeunes filles qui ont 17 ans elles
doivent partir en australie mais
malheureusement elle s'arrête en
slovénie dans une maison qui est un
petit peu particulière un petit peu
mystérieuse sur laquelle il ya un
terrain de fouilles archéologiques à
partir de ce moment là un nouveau monde
va s'ouvrir à ces deux adolescentes
qui parle de la protection des animaux
sauvages les différents problèmes qui
sont liés à l'homme et comment à hauteur
d'enfant on peut faire des actions qui
peuvent changer cette situation en tout
cas améliorer cette situation
[Musique]
une histoire d'anticipation qui part de
la montée des multinationales qui vont
décider de numériser l'ensemble des
livres de la planète
et brûlé tout ce qui est
du papier de manière à pouvoir avoir un
contrôle sur ce qui peut être lu par la
population tous ces auteurs pour faire
des séances de dédicaces il y aura
également des animations en continu
comme des jeux des expositions encore
des lectures c'est une programmation
assez dense pour cette première année à
ses dons d'autant plus qu'il ya aussi
des cafés de l'auteur donc des sortes de
conférence il y aura aussi des
conférences une large
les auteurs
prestigieux qui vont pouvoir me parler
justement de leur leur appréhension du
monde de demain et en complément du
salon en présentiel vous l'avez dit en
introduction au vélodrome vous avez su
organiser un salon du livre en digital
qu'est ce que l'on pourra voir eh ben
vous pourrez tout voir tout revoir qui
aura des podcasts mais vous pourrez
participer à toutes et à tous les
événements importants du salon mais
aussi à d'autres événements qui seront
dédiés à ce salon digital et on donne
l'adresse à nos téléspectateurs c'est
sky les visionnaires point virtual faire
point fr voilà est donc cette page est
accessible jusqu'au 8 avril si je
voterai pas exactement soit jusqu'au
ville aux mille merci beaucoup eric à
leur jeunesse et leurs amis des mercis
saint-quentin-en-yvelines décerne un
prix littéraire à un auteur toi roman a
dit également en compétition depuis le
16 novembre 2021 les internautes
pouvaient également de vie leur vote en
ligne
[Musique]
sur le thème de la ville de demain ils
étaient trois à concourir pour le prix
du livre de saint quentin en yvelines
gaspard koenig avec l'enfer delphine de
vigan hauteur de les enfants sont rois
et michael christie avec son roman
lorsque les derniers arbres
c'est finalement l'auteur canadien qui
remporte cette récompense son roman
raconte l'histoire d'une famille
américaine assombrie par une
accumulation de secret et de tabous sur
quatre générations des années 1930 aux
années 2030 où les personnages sont
intimement lié à celui des arbres ja oui
je suis très content je suis honoré je
voulais écrire un livre qui s'engagent
pour l'écologie la nature avec notre
rôle dans la protection de la nature
c'est pour cela que j'ai utilisé le
sujet des armes le prix du livre était
décerné à moitié par des lecteurs et par
un jury composé de neuf professionnels
une majorité pour michael christie mais
quand même une façon de signaler que les
deux autres heures avait aussi une
portée quand même un regard sur la
société actuelle les fans étaient aussi
au rendez-vous pour saluer le travail de
michael christie tu viens de demander
une dédicace amical christie parce que
j'ai adoré son livre j'ai déjà lu mais
j'ai même voté pour lui justement pour
qu'il obtienne le crime j'adore c'est
génial c'est vraiment un honneur de
participer à cette première édition du
salon du livre et je suis sûr qu'il y en
aura d'autres après et lors de la
cérémonie de remise de prix l'auteur a
remporté la somme de 5000 euros
l'écrivain travaille désormais avec des
producteurs pour adapter son roman à la
télévision il devrait également sortir
un nouveau livre prochainement le prix
du livre a donc été remis par guillaume
martin nous l'avons rencontrée regarder
guillaume martin bonjour vous êtes le
président du jury du prix du livre de
saint quentin en yvelines on vous
connaît surtout en tant que cycliste
professionnel au sein de l'équipe
cofidis vous êtes arrivé 8e du dernier
tour de france mais vous avez aussi
d'autres corde à votre arc vous êtes
philosophe et écrivain d'ailleurs vous
vous considérez comme veloz of
participer à un salon du juré le
président du jury qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous déjà c'est une
expérience nouvelle pour voir shrek jeu
plutôt habitué à sur le vélo ou à écrire
sur mon loisir mais là c'est une
responsabilité particulière quand même
que de
devoir décider d'un un prix littéraire
donc moi je les
en tout cas je les ai vécus avec plaisir
après ce qui est original et un peu un
hasard heureux c'est le fait que ce
salon littéraire international meurt le
vélodrome de la fédération de 2
française de cyclisme donc voilà ça
réunit un peu mais de mes deux univers
les trois romans compétition a évoqué
les trois ans de demain l'évolution de
notre monde en quoi c'est une thématique
intéressante pour les lecteurs
je pense que la littérature se nourrit
d'imaginaire s'est toujours nourri
l'imaginaire et et qu'elle a aussi
quelque chose à
vous enseignez sur sur notre temps et
sur ce que société aussi peut devenir et
le biais de la fiction à apporte quelque
chose d'autre et enrichit
vision en tout cas c'est pour des
lecteurs c'est passionnant parce que
c'est
vous pose des questions et
et en même temps c'est fascinant en
séries en vérité vous êtes auteur comme
on disait l'auteur de socrate à vélo et
le dernier que vous venez de sortir la
société du boulot ton philosophie de
l'individu dans le groupe dans ce qui
vous fait un parallèle entre le et la
société justement en quoi le peloton est
à l'image de la société rapidement en
quelques mots non si c'est difficile de
résumer un livre en quelques mois
en tout cas moi mon le coeur de mon
livre il avait trait aux
problèmes de la du lien entre individuel
et collectif je pense que c'est un sujet
qui nous touche tous
aujourd'hui où on est à la fois porté
par des ambitions
individuels dans une société hyper
individualiste et en même temps on est
quand même
toujours
questionné par cette notion de vivre
ensemble et je pense que dans fait dans
le peloton il ya ça de manière
exemplaire il ya le fait que peuple à
gagner sans les autres par exemple sans
déconner cliquer et en même temps les
autres c'est aussi ce qui
ce qui nous énerve parfois on n'a qu'une
envie c'est d'être d'échapper à ce
peloton dans socrates à vélo vous
essayez de dénoncer les clichés sur les
sportives qui sont considérés parfois
comme ignorants est-ce que allait
présider un salon du livre c'est
également combattre ces préjugés oui en
tout cas pas dans toutes mes
et prises de position publiques
par mon parcours j'ai c'est de montrer
que voilà on n'est pas obligé être rangé
dans une seule case et qu'on peut être
plusieurs choses en même temps dans la
vie et pour finir guillaume martin et
vous des projets futurs un livre au delà
de votre saison à vélo un livre en
écriture moi j'ai toujours des projets
après là pour l'instant la saison et a
redémarré je suis avant tout évidemment
préoccupé par ma saison cycliste et les
projets sont encore vraiment l'état de
projet mais j'ai toujours des choses est
écrit merci beaucoup bien de martin
d'avoir été notre invité pour faire
découvrir les écrivains du salon des
cafés d'auteur sont organisés pour
échanger autour de leurs livres des
dédicaces sont aussi au programme
une dédicace en forme de décence 7
plaisir oise vient tout juste de
l'obtenir là j'ai eu un super cadeau
c'est la dédicace dont de brice
qui m'a fait un superbe illustration de
cet album bd qui doit être génial dans
les allées du salon du livre de saint
quentin en yvelines les visiteurs
peuvent discuter avec les auteurs et
recherchent souvent les dédicaces on
al'occasion discuté avec l'auteur en
direct donc je pense que ça va un petit
peu plus vivant que juste aller chercher
un livre sur une étagère ça me fait
plaisir parce que quand il quand je lis
des livres
ben j'ai l'impression d'entrer dans leur
vie en quelque sorte et ça me fait
plaisir de les rencontrer pour voir
comment ils maison écrit
leur imagination de cauet se soit
inspiré quand on maîtrise est assez
solitaire on fait des vidéos dans son
jardin on écrit un livre en herbe une
seule dans son bureau et là c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer les gens de
pouvoir discuter d'échanger et c'est
agréable aussi de d'avoir cette
rencontre physique le salon du livre
organise aussi des cafés d'auteur
pendant 30 minutes électeurs sont
invités à rencontrer un auteur et les
poser des questions le but échanger sur
leurs derniers ouvrages c'est très
agréable de voir quelqu'un qu'on
respecte qu'on aime beaucoup et pouvoir
poser des questions sur on veut c'est
très intéressant ça permet évidemment
d'exciter la curiosité de gens qui vous
connaissent pas forcément disons que
c'est qualitativement plus intéressant
puisqu'on attend de discuter avec les
gens et pour les enfants des séances de
lecture était également au programme
autre prix remis à celui de la nouvelle
les étudiants de l'ub est est ce qu ont
pu participer à ce salon en écrivant des
nouvelles sur leur vision de la ville de
demain le prix de la nouvelle honda
selon des visionnaires
être début mai
[Musique]
margon
c'est cette jeune étudiante de
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines où qui remporte le prix de la
nouvelle du salon du livre les
visionnaires très content très fier que
ce texte ait été entendu je suis fier de
ce que j'ai fait parce que je trouve que
j'ai vraiment assumé mon écriture et
c'était mon premier texte abouti en fait
écrit et en ce moment un appel à
écriture lancé par le salon du livre aux
étudiants depuis le 1er mars sur le
thème imaginez vous la ville de demain
l'occasion pour margaux étudiante en
master littéraire décrire sa première
nouvelle cercle solaire c'est un peu à
un monologue théâtral poétique
cie présente une ville enfouie sous
terre parce que le soleil a brûlé la
surface de la table une centaine
d'élèves ont pu participer à ce concours
évaluée autour de trois critères par les
membres du jury la pertinence par
rapport au thème est ce que c'était
vraiment bien dans le sujet de la ville
de demain l'inventivité est ce que c'est
une intrigue attractive intéressante est
ce qu'on rentre dedans le style
l'écriture la qualité de du langage
savait que les étudiants de lettres
allaient réagir bien sûr mais on ne
pensait pas que des étudiants viendrait
donc l'aide espagnole de 3 d'histoire
les dix premiers gagnants verront leurs
nouvelles publié un livre audio sera
réalisé dans les catalogues des
médiathèques de cinq enfants nul et
c'est la fin de cette suite culture
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous la semaine prochaine dans un autre
lieu culturel yves binois bonne soirée
sur télé 70
[Musique]